IT WILL BE ITCHING TO SEE WHAT
THE KING HAS TO THAT HAS TO SAY.
CHRIS: ENTERING HIS FOURTH
SEASON IN THE PURPLE AND GOLD,
35,000 367 POINTS, HE IS AN NFL
ANALYST NOW, LEBRON JAMES.
THAT WAS FUN.
WELCOME.
LEBRON: APPRECIATE IT.
I APPRECIATE THAT, MAN.
CHRIS: I GET EXCITED FOR THESE
THINGS.
ALLIE AND I WERE ON THE PHONE
LAST NIGHT TALKING ABOUT MEDIA
DAY.
WE ARE GOING THROUGH OUR
QUESTIONS AND THEN YOU CAME ON
ESPN WITH THE MANNING BROTHERS.
WE NEVER SPOKE AGAIN.
MY ONE QUESTION BEFORE WE GET
INTO BASKETBALL.
PAYTON MANNING PUTS YOU ON THE
SPOT, THERE'S ONLY TWO SECONDS
LEFT AND HE SAYS WHAT PLAYER
THEY RUNNING.
YOU WERE SMOOTH UNDER FIRE, YOU
SAID HANDOFF TO ZEKE, PAYTON
ERUPTED.
HOW FUN WAS THAT MOMENT?
LEBRON: IT WAS VERY FUN.
I'M A BIG-TIME FOOTBALL GUY.
I WAS READING THE DEFENSE LIKE I
DOING BASKETBALL.
I SAW THE EAGLES ONLY HAD THREE
DEFENSIVE LINEMAN, THE
LINEBACKERS WERE PLAYING DEEP.
THEY JUST RAN THE HALFBACK DRAW
THE PLAY BEFORE AND GOT A BUNCH
OF YARDS.
I FELT LIKE THEY WOULD GO RIGHT
BACK TO IT BECAUSE PHILLY DIDN'T
CHANGE THEIR DEFENSE.
MIKE MCCARTHY AND THE OFFENSIVE
COORDINATOR MAKING ME LOOK GOOD.
CHRIS: OUR FAVORITE PART WAS
WHEN PAYTON SCOLDED ELI AND SAID
LEBRON IS THE SYSTEM.
ALLIE: ELI WAS TRYING TO DO WITH
THE RIGHT WAY.
LEBRON: THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS,
THAT IS THE BIG BROTHER FOR YOU.
CHRIS: ENTERING YOUR 19 SEASON.
YOU ARE THE LEAGUE'S THIRD
ALL-TIME LEADING SCORER.
MOST GUYS ARE SAILING OFF INTO
THE SUNSET.
THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE YOUR
STYLE.
WHAT IS YOUR EXCITEMENT LEVEL
HEADING INTO THIS TRAINING CAMP?
LEBRON: I'M SUPER EXCITED.
I KNOW FOR SURE I WON'T BE ABLE
TO SLEEP TONIGHT GOING INTO THE
FIRST DAY OF PRACTICE TOMORROW.
I LOVE THE GROUP WE PUT TOGETHER
THIS SUMMER.
I LOVE THE GROWTH OF THE GUYS
THAT ARE COMING BACK.
I CANNOT WAIT.
I COULD FEEL IT, I CAN FEEL THE
ENERGY.
IT IS ALL ABOUT NOW, PUTTING IN
THE WORK.
IT IS ALL ABOUT TRUSTING THE
PROCESS, WORKING TOWARDS THE
PROCESS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
I LOVE THE BEGINNING.
I LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING TO
WORK.
JAMES: EVEN AS A YOUNG PLAYER, I
REMEMBER YOU KNOWING HOW TO
UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS OF
PUTTING TOGETHER THE MISSING
PIECES OR ADDING ON PLAYERS.
OVER YOUR CAREER YOU HAVE BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL AT THAT.
TALK ABOUT THE ADDITIONS AND
WHAT HAS BEEN MADE THIS YEAR.
THE PLAYERS THAT ARE COMING IN
AND WHAT YOU SEE THEIR VALUE AS
AND HOW THAT IS GOING TO PLAY
OUT IN YOUR OPINION?
LEBRON: I THINK IS GOING TO BE
GRAND FOR OUR TEAM.
WE HAD A LOT OF SHOTMAKING.
WE ADDED SOME DYNAMIC PLAYERS
THAT COULD DO MULTIPLE THINGS
WITH THE BALL AND WITHOUT THE
BALL.
WE ADDED SOME LENGTH AND SOME
VERTICAL SPACING THAT WE LOST
LAST YEAR.
BRING BACK DWIGHT AND DEANDRE.
THE DYNAMIC WITH THRUSTS AND
WHAT HE BRINGS TO THE TEAM, HIS
ENERGY, PACE, COMPETITIVE
NATURE.
WE BROUGHT BACK CHAMPIONSHIP
PLAYERS, TREVOR ARIZA.
UNSUNG GUYS THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY KNOW ABOUT
BUT THEY WILL BRING SO MUCH TO
OUR TEAM.
KENT BAZEMORE, KENDRICK NUNN.
WHAT THEY BRING TO THE TABLE IS
RIDICULOUS.
WAYNE ELLINGTON'S SHOT ABILITY.
LET ME NOT FORGET THE GROWTH
ONCE AGAIN, ANOTHER SUMMER FOR
TALEN HORTON-TUCKER.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT HIM AND WHAT
HE WILL BRING FOR OUR TEAM.
WE ARE DYNAMIC.
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO A LOT
OF DIFFERENT THINGS OUT ON THE
FLOOR.
IT IS UP TO US TO PUT THE TIME
IN, WHICH WE WILL.
I WILL HOLD THIS TEAM
ACCOUNTABLE AND THEY WILL HOLD
ME ACCOUNTABLE.
ALLIE: STARTING AT THE TOP WHEN
IT COMES TO YOU GUYS AS PLAYERS,
THERE'S A LOT OF TALK ABOUT YOU
AND RUSSELL, RIGHTFULLY SO.
WE WILL GET INTO THE FIT OF THE
THREE OF U.S. STARS IN A MINUTE.
THERE'S ALSO ANOTHER GUY NAMED
ANTHONY DAVIS.
IT SEEMS LIKE SOME PEOPLE HAVE
FORGOT ABOUT HIM.
LEBRON: GOOD.
ALLIE: WHAT DOES A REJUVENATED
ANTHONY DAVIS LOOK LIKE?
LEBRON: A LOT OF PEOPLE GOING TO
THE SUMMER AND POST THEIR
WORKOUTS, THEIR TRAINING, THAT
THEY ARE DOING.
IF THERE WAS ONE GUY THAT YOU
DID NOT SEE THIS SUMMER UNTIL HE
GOT MARRIED LAST WEEK IT WAS
ANTHONY DAVIS.
I KNEW EVERYTHING HE WAS DOING.
PUTTING IN THE WORK.
BOTH IN THE WEIGHT ROOM AND ALSO
ON THE COURT.
HE'S DETERMINED TO -- IT'S NOT
EVEN ABOUT PROVING PEOPLE WRONG.
IT'S ABOUT PROVING HIMSELF
RIGHT.
YOU KNOW WHAT HE COULD BRING TO
THE TABLE.
HE'S ONE OF THE BEST PLAYERS WE
HAVE IN THIS LEAGUE.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO A VERY
ANGRY ANTHONY DAVIS.
THE ANTHONY DAVIS I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING THIS YEAR WILL
BE EQUIVALENT WITH THE GREEN BAY
PACKERS LOST ON A SUNDAY.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT ONE.
CHRIS: DID YOU KNOW HE COULD
SING LIKE THAT?
LEBRON: I ACTUALLY DID.
YOU GET A LITTLE EXCITEMENT.
YOUR FAMILY AND FRIENDS ARE
THERE.
MIX IT WITH A LITTLE ALCOHOL AND
YOU CAN DO A LOT OF THINGS.
CHRIS: WE GET BRAVE.
LEBRON: REAL BRAVE, THE LIQUID
COURAGE.
CHRIS: THE ADDITION OF RUSSELL,
A LOT OF THE TALK HAS BEEN THE
FIT WITH YOU AND A.D., THE
SACRIFICES EVERYONE WILL HAVE TO
MAKE.
HOW DO YOU ENVISION THIS
LOOKING?
LEBRON: FOR ONE, I HAVE HEARD OF
BEFORE.
WHEN I DECIDED TO GO TO MIAMI
THE FIRST THING THEY SAID WAS
LEBRON AND D. WADE DON'T MESH.
THERE'S NO WAY THEY COULD PLAY
TOGETHER.
TOO BALL DOMINANT.
YOU CAN'T SHOOT THE BALL FROM
THE PERIMETER.
IT IS NOT GOING TO WORK.
TOO SIMILAR PLAYERS.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED WITH
THAT.
YOU MAKE IT WORK.
YOU FIGURE IT OUT.
I KNOW WHAT RUSS BRINGS TO THE
TABLE.
WHEN YOU HAVE A UNICORN LIKE
A.D., HE FITS INTO ANYTHING.
THEY SAID ME AND A.D. WOULDN'T
WORK.
I DON'T REALLY GET CAUGHT UP IN
THE NARRATIVE AT THIS POINT.
THAT IS ALL PART OF JUST TRYING
TO SELL TABLOIDS.
I'M 19 YEARS INTO THIS THING.
I KNOW WHAT IS ALL ABOUT.
THE GAME IS WON BETWEEN THE FOUR
LINES.
IT IS NOT WON IN THE PAPER, THE
BOTTOM TICKER, IT IS WON BETWEEN
THESE FOUR LINES, 94 FEET.
WE HAVE A JOB TO DO.
CHRIS: YOU LOOK WONDERFUL IN
YOUR NUMBER SIX.
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING READY.
WE WILL LET YOU GO BECAUSE YOU
HAVE A LOT TO DO TODAY.
ALWAYS LOVE SPENDING TIME WITH
YOU, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LEBRON: APPRECIATE IT CHRIS,
ALLIE, BIG GAME JAMES.
LOVE YOU GUYS.
CHRIS: THAT WAS LEBRON JAMES.
ENTERING HIS 19 SEASON.
THE THIRD ALL-TIME LEADING
SCORER PATOIS AND -- BEHIND KARL
MALONE AND